on va passer aux premiers matches de la
soirée le premier mac et là ça va être
chaud parce qu'on va pas en revenir on
va revenir sur les propos d'eric zemmour
sur les prénoms français sont ils
racistes
donc les propos de zemmour sur les
prénoms français sont ils racistes c'est
la question qu'on va vous poser le
premier match de la soirée
ils vont opposer eric revel ex patron de
lci à agathe au cou alors ex-patron
syrie de chez elle juste un oui je
voulais faire remarquer quelque chose
aucune chance de gagner le débat c'est
la faute aux d'agathe oui oui ça c'est
la mienne grand débat cette semaine les
propos d'eric zemmour alors bien sûr
l'îlot récap des faits c'est tout de
suite regardé on va vous mettre en place
pour le premier match et c'est vous qui
allez voter qui va gagner ce premier
match c'est parti on y va c'est la
polémique du moment dans le monde des
médias
les propos d'eric zemmour dans les
terriens du dimanche sur ces 8 mais
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé je ne
sais plus aujourd'hui on vous résultat
dimanche sur ces 8 lors d'un débat sur
l'identité nationale le célèbre
polémiste a dit ça normalement chez moi
on doit donner des prénoms dans ce qu'on
appelle le calendrier c'est à dire les
saints chrétiens
une petite phrase qui a fait réagir
hapsatou sy en plateau je m'appelle à
fait tort elle a eu tort vous voudriez
donc je m'appelle comment corinne ça te
dirait très bientôt
puis sur les réseaux sociaux sur le
plateau j'ai subi des insultes graves
je réfléchis à quitter l'émission très
vite la polémique enfle tous les médias
s'emparent de la sphère le crèche
week-end sur le plateau de thierry
ardisson polémique autour d'eric zemmour
qu'eric zemmour eric zemmour eric
zemmour est du côté d'eric zemmour pas
question d'apaiser les tensions au
contraire il assume ses propos et
n'hésite pas à enfoncer le clou sur les
plateaux télé jeunes un jury personne
j'ai dit la même chose à rachida dati il
n'y a pas de porte de sortie après parce
qu'en l'occurrence c'est elle qui prend
la porte de sortie puisqu'elle est tiré
de l'émission
alors selon vous les propos d'eric
zemmour sur les prénoms français sont
ils racistes et c'est le premier match
du soir eric revel à ma droite donc qui
lui trouve que les propos d'eric zemmour
ne sont pas restés en tout cas
m'interroge matériaux agathopedia il se
trouve que les propos d'eric zemmour
sont racistes vous réagissez chez vous
une direct pour vous qui vous a le plus
convaincu
doc gynéco continue à prendre des notes
apparemment il fait une dictée safina le
carnet à spirales oui la callas spirale
il a tout il a tout il est allé il est à
dix juste avant la librairie les chéris
une minute chacun pouvait vous couper
comme vous voulez comme dans l'ordre
liées des présidentielles par contre
vous avez plus une stature
présidentielle comme ça les agace aussi
l'attention c'est parti pour une minute
pour livre qui commence
si vous regardez donc eric vous allez
nous expliquer que les propos d'eric
zemmour aussi scandaleux soit-il ne soit
pas ne sont pas racistes
alors attendez je m'interroge depuis le
début de cette séquence je vais d'abord
j'aimerais faire juste un petit
préalable rapide après je me serai là
avec une minute dans c'est que c'est que
ces propos qu'ils aient trouvé choquant
parce que quand on dit à une personne
comme axa tout que cinq cents c'est une
insulte à la république d'avoir un tel
prénom
moi j'ai envie de dire d'entrée après je
vous dirai pourquoi il faut pas
confondre des choses j'ai envie de dire
d'entrée avec zemmour
souviens toi mon cher eric des gens qui
s'appelait nos gars driss faille qui
était tirailleurs sénégalais sont morts
pour la france et leurs prénoms
justement sont un honneur pour la france
et donc vous donner les propos
paraissent alors maintenant je ne dois
pas trop de secondes eric d'accord alors
les i le débat va être côté rap très
rapidement je me suis permis d'ouvrir un
dictionnaire est de sortir la définition
du racisme que vous pourrez trouver dans
n'importe quel dictionnaire le racisme
et je cite l'expression d'une
discrimination et d'une hostilité envers
un groupe yum humains ici dans ce cas
précis envers les citoyens français ne
portant pas de prêts longs 10 français
autre définition du racisme une
idéologie qui s'élance souvigné
archifaux vraie machine à gagner
il ya donné la hiérarchie ici c'est
curieux c'est que les dons davantage
leur place en france que les personnes
ne portant pas de prêt de laisser l'eau
par les tac une minute il m'en reste 40
il faut ouvrir un livre de de zemmour en
fait il a une cohérence idéologique il a
une cohérence idéologique c'est à dire
que ils pensent ils à droite défendent
cette thèse que la france qu'ils
l'aiment est en train de se dissoudre
dans ce qu'il appelle le
multiculturalisme à nice-matin dérivés
attendez je termine et la sphère des
prénoms la sphère des prénoms c'est pour
lui un morceau du puzzle c'est à dire
que il considère à tort ou à raison
qu'un prénom c'est un marqueur culturel
et idéologique et il dit donc
idéologique froid que c'est terminé
attendons peu en réussite a toujours des
gens vivent alors vous c'est terminé
mais il y aurait cinq ans 20 secondes
vous c'est terminé vous n'avez plus qu'à
la regarder mais rose et les crevettes
ne doit regarder non mais j'avais nom
mais dont le prénom est un marqueur et
théologique le prénom français permet
une insertion plus facile dans le pays
bla bla bla bla donc au lieu de
combattre racisme latent et dérangeant
au lieu d'aller que l'autre c'est
d'évidence discriminatoire on va appeler
mention de chance j'en arrive enfin que
son mari sera peut-être pas le bon choix
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je ne peux pas ne pas y aller si vite je
vous donnais une phrase ericsson de
rugby bernard laporte s'est peut-être
bailly défaite federer il a fait naître
la fédération suisse a terminé cette
chaussée qui joue en pro 2 oui à massy
et qui a décidé de franciser et son
prénom et son nom alors s'appelle alors
alors c'est la propagande à la voix vous
avez terminé j'avais peur ce n'est pas
terminé
c'est pas pareil il n'était pas trop
déçu pour tous à vos placements sudan
aux platines
[Applaudissements]